so he's like in a circle and you can see
I've got a point on the circumference of
the circle by the way that particular
point what Sita would give me that point
zero this is where I begin isn't it so I
would begin from here and then I would
start going anti-clockwise and speed up
increases in size does that make sense
okay so what does that happen I just
added over here on the left-hand side
you can't quite make it out
but this slider here is my slider speed
up okay so I'm actually just going to
bet it as a little bit so as I get up to
a 90 you can see what's going on and
there it is a nine are you happy with
that much an end off gr so that's what
you'll need it certainly we keep going
around the sort of cut into the
illustration because in our diagram
understand the first quarter so let me
bring it back the opposite okay now I'm
going to show you the first one one of
the first ones you guys get signing
cause I'm gonna show you can is top tier
ten get caught okay let me put a trigger
might wrinkle however that that looks
something like the yeah the diagrams we
created okay so this orange lady it's
length is 10 feet and the Purple Line
Italy is Katya okay just think about
this stick came to earth pay zero twenty
ten years zero zero of course it has to
be because watch what happens to be
already lied when I drag us back in a
starting point okay
do you see where the orange line is it's
uh it's right there right it's not going
anywhere because 1000 right and speed it
increases what happens to thank you as
speed increases Cantina gets bigger and
bigger and bigger at a certain point it
doesn't just start growing slowly he
assumed a little bit at a certain point
its growth just skyrocketed like that
right
do you see how little I have to drag
this and how much longer that get right
do you have an image I can see the graph
in your mind what is 10 C to do as a
duration door tonight increases
increase and then it just sort of takes
off right in etiquettes 95 why not
well from the grass for you because I
have an accent to it but that begs the
question why do I have an accent to an
answer come back to the diagram right
look what's happening to that tangent
look what happens look what happens oh
wait I never actually need to sit with
the actress again now you remember how
to connect the essence and that length
is 10 meter when you don't connect to
the axes so there's no delay so 10 P is
that make sense
it also tells you why let's rewind a
little bit right do you remember we did
the graphs all can't Peter and coffee
table okay chief okay until you would
like to stop don't like that that's the
first pot of handy what was the first
part of coffee to look like it starts
off with an acetone and then it drops
down it does the reverse with what
Tanja's right as this increases this
decreases do you see it do you see why
look let me go back again if I started
zero can a zero and zero and then I just
needed a little bit plan there copier
I wouldn't cough it up it's enormous
of course it's enormous could look at
right next to its vertical asymptote you
see that and then as I approach 90 look
what happens to the copier it drops down
of course it drops down because look it
gets shorter and shorter and shorter and
shorter until it doesn't exist anymore
do not it this you can make the same
argument that's all that damn that's
some cannon caught fool by the way
important angle TV that's fine have a
look at that for you I'm looking for me
if 1000 Linda
if this is 10 45 years 45 right what did
I tell you about the angle between the
radius and a tangent what I told I'm any
is perpendicular this is a dream that
makes this angle here this is 45 45 90
or can train like this it's isosceles
which is why this is the unit circle is
1 this is 10
it's also one 1045 has to be one could
you form an isosceles triangle with the
radius of music
does that make sense yes it okay lastly
let's have a look at there's attention
and I need that guy that's sex Kingdom
numbness and there's Christic I don't
know how to see could be on the axis
right but hopefully you can make out
what happens for example general where
to 0 I did my angle viewer it is sick
jeong-seon what is sec what's the graph
of sex reply do you remember it's been a
while I saw one right let me help you
John Mary check is the reciprocal of its
cause right sir Jesus here's the claw
draft right so the sec graph looks like
a bit like that right it started
wondering why does that one look at it
there is because there at that
particular moment is the radius of the
unit circle which is one okay and then
and see here increases what happens to
sec the senior increases with moral and
good it goes further and further and
further away and that a certain point it
just skyrockets right like that
just like Candis does that make sense in
exactly the same way if you wanna think
about this great guy let's go back to
you
it's bring either here okay this is
heuristic is it says protect doesn't
even exist at the moment why not
let's go sexier Cossacks 0 is 1 over
sine 0 is it fit but that's 1 over 0
undefined okay but then as soon as you
start moving I'm just going to do that
for later ok
it starts become down to 1 see that
because that's exactly what the Christic
grasp does the co-state graph looks like
this let's put a little it's what it's
asking for again and it looks like that
generally this one that's correct
remember do you see as I move from
between 0 and 90 I'm moving between CR
and she arm that's a little part I'm
moving between ok so now you know why
cycle time why cuz I'm called code 9 why
it all fits together is because of
what's happening on the unit circle
right that's why unit circle so much
more powerful way of ending so just a
simple run have it